hey how are you welcome to PlayStation
grenade so you're enjoying your holiday
time away from work or education but
before you know it it'll already be 2019
to help you prepare for the new year
here are 9 great games releasing in
January 2019 please let me know if you'd
like to see any on the channel in fact
saying that there's nowhere else we
could begin Resident Evil 2 remake
arrives on January 25th will be playing
the remake from start to finish here on
PlayStation granade so if you don't
fancy experiencing the horror all alone
then we can get through it together by
now I think everyone on the planet knows
what Resident Evil is but to be honest
that message has become a little muddied
after the action movie shenanigans of re
5 & 6 & the first-person survival
reincarnation of re 7 a few years back
so let's make it clear Resident Evil is
returning to its survival-horror roots
taking the great starting setting of the
Raccoon City Police Department from the
og Resident Evil 2 and matching it up
with the third-person camera angles used
in Resident Evil 4 this won't be like an
80s action film there won't be enough
ammunition to take down all the undead
and with an unstoppable juggernaut
pursuing us things are gonna get tense
if you remember the original or if you
are still wondering why are we - is
clusters the best Resident Evil game you
can see for yourself on January 25th I
won't lie I'm so hyped for this one I've
already purchased my adult diapers
Capcom have a second notable game
releasing in January Onimusha wallets
Onimusha places as in the shoes of some
earnest gay who is tasked with rescuing
a princess ok so that was the story to
every videogame 20 years ago but in this
one we play as a samurai-sama nosce is
equipped with a gauntlet to seal the
demon souls - hang on come to mention it
although Onimusha is most definitely a
hack-and-slash action extravaganza
many early elements of the Dark Soul
series exist here timing counter-attacks
and watching for patterns in enemy
movement to exploit towards victory
unlike Resident Evil 2 Onimusha is a
remaster not a remake basically meaning
the visuals have been updated with minor
tweaks gameplay mechanics for example
the camera angles remain fixed in place
as was the norm 20 years ago this can be
a pain on
occasion but heck you're a badass
samurai live the dream Onimusha warlords
releases on January 15th and if it does
well maybe we could see that franchise
return for a new outing okay this is
questionable but I'm going to add it
anyway anthem PA and Bioware's attempt
at sci-fi perpetual shared open-world
RPG bloody hell that's a mouthful is set
to release in February so why is it on
the list
now well it comes down to pre-order
bonuses only you can decide if you love
them or hate them but I wanted to make
you aware all the same those that
pre-order anthem will have access to the
VIP beta from January 25th to the 27th
the standard Edition also comes with an
armored pack and weapon but we'll
discuss that near at the time there's an
open beta for those who don't want to
pay for something which they haven't
actually experienced yet so on February
the 1st running to the 3rd everyone can
take part in an open beta for anthem I
took part in the closed alpha and
although I can't openly talk about it
due to an NDA I can recommend that you
try the beta for yourself and as you can
see for yourself it's like Iron Man the
division and destiny all smashed
together into a perfect little package
we'll have to see if it lives up to this
but if there's a pink color scheme count
me in the full game releases on February
22nd I fully intend to cover anthem in
much more detail over the next few
months did you ever play the Kingdom
Hearts series sadly I never picked up a
copy and completely missed the hype
train Kingdom Hearts 3 is looking to get
more of us on board this long-running
saga and kicks off on January the 29th
Kingdom Hearts throws together Disney
Pixar and Final Fantasy characters or
art styles to create a standalone
universe this is said to be the final
chapter in the series with a storyline
which may need breaking down before
playing to get the best out of the
narrative I'm sure that will happen in
the opening cinematic in terms of
gameplay Kingdom Hearts has always been
hack and slash role-playing game with
that oversized key sword which I'm
thinking about buying for my wall you'll
be jumping around from different
location two different worlds such as
visiting Disney's Tangled and even
Andy's room from Toy Story those that
play Kingdom Hearts recommend it highly
so will you give it a try I'd love to
know your thoughts
next Ace Combat seven skies unknown a
flight simulator in 2019 I'm surprised
because we don't really see games
attempt aviation only eight combat has
been perfecting the genre since 1995
with five years passing since the last
iteration the game is set in 2019 during
a conflict between two fictional
countries and the impending threat of
unmanned drones and political unrest the
voice acting is impressive and conveys
the moment-to-moment decision-making a
highly skilled pilot makes and of course
you'll get to shoot things like your in
Top Gun man I miss goose Hayes combat
seven skies unknown hits consoles on
January 18th with PC release in early
February a quick mention to the Tales of
Vesperia I can't believe I'm saying that
in 2019 I feel like this month's theme
is updating videogames from over a
decade ago
the tales series has been with us since
1995 and the highlight for many players
was 2008 Tales of Vesperia which only
appeared in the West on the Xbox 360
this is a typical Japanese RPG just like
Final Fantasy I suppose but battles
occur with real-time elements instead of
characters being glued to the ground
waiting for their turn to deal damage if
you're a JRPG found this one will
already be on your list of games to play
if you don't have the nostalgia or the
love of the Tales franchise this one
might not float your boat tells of
Vesperia definitive edition drops on
January the 11th on Xbox one ps4 switch
and PC January also sees the return of
two episodic adventures life is strange
too episode 2 continues the story of
Sean and Daniel releasing on January
24th but it's the Walking Dead's final
season I'd like to showcase here you may
be unaware the company making the series
telltale games went out of business last
month and let almost all employees go
without a severance package which as you
imagine messed up many people's lives
somehow the remaining bare-bones staff
and outsource workers have been able to
finish the final season of The Walking
Dead and January the 15th will release
episode 3 the penultimate act in
contains story to survive a zombie
apocalypse is it difficult to make if
you want to continue supporting this
franchise now things have changed for
their employees
but if
closure on Clem story it's almost time
and finally Genesis alpha one drops on
January 29th we'll be up in space
discovering worlds and searching for a
new home for our shipmates but get this
the universe is procedurally generated
meaning every location is randomly put
together from a pool of variations we
plane first person as you'd expect and
there's lots of shooting elements but
there's also building elements and
simulation and resource management in
fact this game has so many genres thrown
together it's hard to keep up we can
even play God and splice human DNA with
aliens sure you've all wanted to do that
in the past
Genesis Alpha 1 was due to release in
the summer of 2018 but was pushed back
to January 2019 instead which does worry
me a little bit but time will tell I
suppose interested let us know in the
comments so there you have it 2019 is
kicking off with a bang so many great
games but what floats your boat Resident
Evil 2 Onimusha and maybe I'll try
Kingdom Hearts but what about you I'm
Adam from PlayStation granade it's been
a pleasure see you next time
[Music]